C'est donc sur l'île de la Réunion que s'achève
l'histoire du pirate Olivier Levasseur, dit "La Buse".
En emportant dans sa tombe le secret de son cryptogramme,
il aurait laissé sur l'île une fortune estimée
à plusieurs milliards d'euros.
Aujourd'hui encore, le mystère reste entier.
JB, JB !
JB !
– JB...!
– Ouais ?
Si j'te dis "La Buse", tu penses à quoi ?
– À un oiseau.
– Non.
– C'est pas un oiseau...?
– Non...
Enfin si, mais là, j'te parle du pirate
qui a caché son trésor sur l'île de la Réunion.
Et on est juste à côté.
Et on est... dessus, en fait.
On est sur l'île de la Réunion.
Enfin bref ! C'que j'te propose,
c'est qu'on se sorte les doigts,
– qu'on trouve le trésor,
– Ouais...
et on est riches, mon pote.
Ou alors...
Jet Ski !
– Bon, j'te promet, c'est la dernière boutique qu'on fait.
– Et après, on fait le Jet Ski, c'est ça ?
– C'est ça !
– Ok. Cool.
Viens, c'est là.
Oui ?
Oui, bonjour. Nous... cherchons des renseignements sur La Buse.
– C'est un oiseau.
– Ah, tu vois !
Nan, j'veux parler du pirate.
Le pirate ?
Non, j'ai rien pour vous ici.
Et ça, c'est quoi ?
C'est dingue, ce truc...
– C'est un sudoku ?
– Non, j'pense que c'est un message codé.
C'est des mots mêlés, p'têt'.
Non, vraiment, j'pense que c'est un message codé.
"Papaye" !
Non j'ai trouvé "Papaye" dans la diagonale...
Regarde, t'sais, juste là, là...
Putain mais t'es con !
– Merde ça a un peu coulé...
– Tu crois ?!
Hé...!
Qu'est-ce que vous faites, là ?
Hein ?
Derrière vous, un pélican !
Euh... Pardon...!
Écoute j'en sais rien, j'suis passé devant le musée Manu Payet
et là, j'suis paumé...
Mais je sais pas, j'ai plus une thune, j'suis paumé,
j'en ai aucune idée, j'en sais rien du tout...
Vous êtes taxi ?!
Oui.
À l'hôtel Gecko, le plus vite possible !
– Et bien très b...
– Dépêche-toi, Valéry !
– Ha ha ha !
– Qu'est-ce qui t'as pris, putain ?
– J'ai improvisé...
– Ouais ben, n'improvise plus jamais, ok ?
Un pélican... N'importe quoi !
Ça va, c'est ça les vacances...!
Apparemment, c'est sur une île...
Sans déconner...?
Dîtes !
Si vous cherchez un guide...
Moi, j'en connais un très bien,
qui connait l'île comme ma poche.
Du coup, si vous voulez aller au Piton
de la Fournaise ou autre hein,
lui, il saura.
– J'avais pas compris qu'c'était, lui le guide, moi !
– Ouais, moi non plus...
Eh, t'sais quoi ? Viens, on rentre, on arrête tout...!
On s'pose tranquillement chez nous
et après, t'sais quoi? On repart, on fait du...
'Tention les vagues !
Slalom !
– Du tennis...?
– Mais non, du Jet Ski !
Mais évidemment du Jet Ski, j'vais pas...
Eh, dîtes ! 'Voudriez pas m'filer la carte, là,
plutôt que d'vous engueuler ?
Non j'préfère pas...!
Comme vous voulez. M'enfin, au moins,
on saurait où on va, quoi...!
Bah...! Vous êtes guide et vous savez pas où on va, vous...?
Si ! Bien sûr ! M'enfin si c'est le Piton de la Fournaise que vous cherchez,
j'ai peur qu'on décroche un peu, là...
– Non non, mais c'est pas le Piton de la Fournaise qu'on cherche.
– On cherche pas le...? Oooh c'est con, merde...
Regardez...!
On arrive sur un plateau aride !
Allez ramenez-vous, les Loustics !
Qu'est-ce qu'on fout dans le Cantal ?
Ouais, alors... La dernière fois que j'suis venu,
c'était vachement plus aride hein, mais bon...
Bon, ben, on va faire le tour, hein !
Allez !
Hein ? Oui ben oui, ça va ! Roh...
Merde...!
Et merde...
Comment ça, "merde" ? Qu'est-ce qu'y s'passe ?
Alors, euh, rien du tout, d'accord hein, tout va bien.
Il faut juste que j'regarde la mousse des arbres,
et selon leur humidité, ce s'ra soit Nord, soit tout droit.
Les arbres...?
– On est paumés, quoi...
– Oui.
– Quoi ?!
– Nan mais eh, c'qu'on fait, vous restez ici.
Vous vous installez tranquillement.
Moi, j'vais chercher du p'tit bois.
Ce soir, feu de camp,
et demain, direction le Pit...!
...ton...
...d'la...
...Fournai...
– C'est l'mec chelou d'la boutique...!
– J't'avais dit de pas lui piquer son bouquin...!
– J'pouvais pas savoir qu'c'était un ninja...!
– C'est quoi ton déo' ?
J'mets pas de déo'...
– C'est ton odeur naturelle...?
– Oui.
– Tu sens vachement bon.
– Merci... Qu'est-ce qu'y fait ?
– J'crois qu'ceci vous appartient...?
– Oh l'enfoiré !
– Bon, moi, j'me casse...!
– Wow wow, attends, qu'est-ce tu fais, là ?
Nan mais c'est bon, ça va;
j'ai soif, on bute des gens,
– ça d'vient n'importe quoi, là...
– Non non, il est juste endormi là, hein.
À moins qu'il soit allergique aux poils de babouk,
ou au venin de cent pieds...
– Ouais, c'est ça... Allez !
– Nan mais attends, qu'est-ce qui t'arrive encore ?
Tu vas pas me laisser tout seul !
On a un trésor à trouver, on est potes non ?
– Ça va, c'est bon... "On est potes"... On était potes au CM2, ok ?
– Quoi ?!
Maintenant j'suis juste un con,
qui t'suis dans tes histoires débiles, là...!
Et lui, il va essayer de nous niquer,
comme l'autre,  j'en suis sûr !
Hé ho, c'est lui qui voulait vous piquer la carte, hein !
Alors moi, direct...
j'le totoche.
"totoche" ?
Le neutralise.
– Tu parles créole, toi...?
– Oui ben, j'me casse de la région, ok ?!
Et lui, maintenant qu'il a la carte,
il va s'barrer avec, c'est évident !
C'est ça ? Z'allez vous barrer avec ?
Nan mais attendez, moi ça fait quinze ans
que j'ai le livre dans ma boutique,
j'comprends rien à cette histoire de cryptogramme,
là j'tombe sur deux mecs qui découvrent la carte, euh...
Non, j'allais vous proposer... 50-50, quoi !
Tu vois ? Ça c'est vachement bien !
Non... Non non...
Moi, j'venais pour les vacances, ok ?
VACANCES !
Ça veut dire JET SKI, JACUZZI, DÉTENTE, ok ?!
Moi j'voulais faire d'la plongée, moi,
j'voulais monter en haut du volcan !
À c'qui parait, t'as une vue magnifique, ok ?!
Ma grand-mère y est allée, apparemment c'est sublime !
J'me casse.
Je suis pas venu pour l'aventure à la con
et les gens qui meurent, moi.
Nan mais il est pas mort, hein !
Tu viens ?
Je sais pas.
Ouais, c'est ça...
J'vais m'amuser, ok ?
L'amusement, moi j'adore ça, moi !
– JB !
– Ta gueule !
Il va faire quoi, là ?
Il... va faire du...
Du tennis...
Ouais c'est ça, ouais.
– Allez, on y va.
– Du tennis...
Si JB pouvait voir ça...!
J'vais le prendre...
FILEZ-MOI C'TRÉSOR !
Ah j'avais pas prévu, ça...!
Eh,
j'suis super énervé, j'me suis pris une fléchette.
En plus, j'ai trouvé un flingue,
donc vous m'filez c'coffre tout d'suite !
Oh, regardez derrière vous, un pélican !
Tu pensais vraiment m'avoir avec une ruse aussi stupide ?
Si si, j'vous assure, il est juste derrière vous !
Non. Y'a pas de pélican, arrête.
Bon ok ok... C'est un bébé pélican... mais il vole !
Arrête avec ça. Y'a pas d'pélican...
Wouoh, hop là !
– 'Tention y vient d'passer juste au-d'ssus d'vot' tête !
– Nan mais stop, ça va... Y'a pas de pélican.
Mais si...!
Y'a pas de pélicans sur l'île de la Réunion !
Mais en revanche, c'que vous avez derrière vous,
c'est un paille-en-queue,
c'est un oiseau typique du coin, qui est très joli
et qui doit son nom à sa longue queue effilée.
C'est un oiseau sublime !
Sublime.
Nan! Merde!
REVENEZ !
– Allez allez, c'pas le moment d'baisser les bras...!
– JB !
REVENEZ, PUTAIN !
MERDE !
PUTAIN !
Brice...
J'crois qu'ceci vous appartient.
– C'est qu'il est un peu différent avec ses lunettes.
– On le reconnait pas.
– P'tite bière ?
– Ouais, grave.
Allez.
T'inquiètes pas papy, ton secret est bien gardé.
Vous cherchez un guide ?
Pour le Piton de la Fournaise !
S'il vous plaît !
J'ai b'soin d'thune ! Venez !
REVENEZ !
Putain...!